[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be once
again comparing and to contrasting the
events of the harry potter books and the
harry potter films i've done quite a few
of these videos recently but most of
them are addressing specific characters
like draco and voldemort this video on
the other hand will be taking a more
general look at the differences between
them
today i'm going to be discussing 15 big
things from the books that were
completely omitted from the films
now there were a lot of aspects of the
books omitted so i certainly won't be
including everything but the ones i've
chosen here should definitely contain
new information for those that have only
seen the films without further ado let's
get started
1. voldemort's death kicking things off
in large fashion we have voldemort's
death in the films after voldemort is
defeated by harry at the end of the
battle of hogwarts his body seems to
disintegrate into nothing however this
does not happen in the books and seem to
be only included for dramatic effect
in the books voldemort simply collapsed
onto the ground just like anyone else
would
incidentally voldemort who sought
immortality for his entire existence
truly died of mortals death
2. the mock slytherin song the sorting
hat song wasn't the only song omitted
from the films and if you didn't know
about that one that's an extra
in fact another important song was
omitted as well a song recreated by
gryffindor students that was devised to
mock southern house and their quidditch
team the song weasley is our king was
actually originally devised by slytherin
students with the goal of mocking ron
referring to him as their king because
of all of the goals that he let in as
keeper however the song was eventually
used against them and modified by the
gryffindor team in order to increase
ron's confidence which in turn
helped them to win the cup
three marauders the marauders a group of
troublesome young boys who attended
hogwarts in the 1970s was comprised of
sirius black remus lupin james potter
and peter pettigrew aka padfoot mooney
prongs and worm tail if you read the
books you'll know about the marauders
but if you didn't then you probably
don't know much in fact the films never
revealed that all four boys learned to
transform into animals became animagi in
order to make remus feel better who was
a werewolf
4. spew
spew aka the society for the promotion
of elfish welfare is an aspect of the
books that didn't appear in the films at
all in the books hermione embarks on a
crusade to ensure that house elves who
are heavily mistreated are saved
hermione starts the society after she
sees winky an elf who isn't in the films
being treated horribly she also took the
time to read up on and understand the
thousands of years of oppression that
they had gone through
5. petunia's rejection petunia dursley
aka petunia evans aka harry's horrible
aunt wasn't always so horrible in 1971
however her path of darkness began as it
was that year that lily her sister
harry's mum received her letter to
hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry it was a momentous occasion for
the family the youngest daughter of the
evans family was a witch when petunia
saw lily receive her letter she felt a
rush of emotions confusion anger but
most of all jealousy and despite not
being magical she felt compelled to
write a letter to none other than albus
dumbledore hoping to be a part of the
magical school herself petunia stated
her case to dumbledore and asked if she
could study there with her sister
however given that petunia was not
magical in any way dumbledore had to
politely decline petunia's request
six dobby gave harry gillyweed in the
gobbler to fire film right before facing
the second task neville longbottom gives
him gillyweed which allows him to
breathe underwater however in the books
though harry still gets gillyweed it's
actually dobby that gives it to him
dobby obtained the killerweed from
snape's office after stealing it using
his elfish magic
7. the elder wand at the end of the
films harry stands amidst the rubble
post battle of hogwarts elder wand in
hand in the very next moment harry snaps
the elder wand in half throwing the
broken pieces off the edge of the path
in the books however the elder wand has
a different fate as harry ends up laying
the one to rest in dumbledore's grave
reunited with its old master
8. marietta edgecombe in the order of
the phoenix harry and others formed
ammodul's army a sort of rebellion that
challenged the tyrannical regime
impressed upon hogwarts by the ministry
it was a place where students could
properly learn how to defend themselves
that is until they were found out in the
films cho chang is shown to be the
reason for the group being exposed
however in the books it's actually cho's
best friend marietta edgecombe that rats
out the group
nine villa in the gobita fire the
students of bobaton walk into the
hogwarts great hall and create quite the
spectacle the male student body is
enamored with the beauty of fleur de la
cor and other female students however
it's never explained why
well the books do explain why it's
because fleur was a villa one quarter
anyway
the concept of avila isn't really
touched on much in the film but those
who read the books know that velas are
semi-human magical beings resembling
beautiful women with white cold hair
villas are known to enchant men in this
form however when angry villas take on
another less pleasant appearance
10. harry entered the cruciatus curse
after hogwarts had been breached by
voldemort in the death eaters it took on
some new staff amicus and alecto caro
to say these professors were unpopular
would be an understatement however
fortunately for harry he did get a
chance to use the cruciatus curse on
amicus caro at one point voldemort sends
death eaters to check on the ravenclaw
tower amicus was among the followers who
demanded entry into the tower from
professor mcgonagall but when mcgonagall
called amicus a coward he spat right in
her face which harry saw firsthand
unable to contain himself harry slammed
amicus into the wall and cast the
torture curse on him 11. rita skeeter
rita skeeter an infamous journalist who
specialized in defamation pieces for the
daily prophet wasn't actually included
much in the films but we still got the
sense that she was awful however in the
books more is revealed about skeeter
like the fact that she was an animagus
that's right mosquito was able to
transform into a beetle which allowed
her to sneak around and collect tons of
juicy info
12. whomping willow the whomping willow
is a staple of the hogwarts grounds
that's featured in both the book and
film in the film harry and ron have a
bit of an issue with it when ron's
flying forward anglia is struck by the
giant tree however beyond this we don't
get a ton of info on the whomping willow
in the books it's revealed that the tree
was planted on the grounds in order to
cover up a secret passage leading from
hogwarts to the shrieking shack this
allowed remus lupin to travel around
unnoticed when he needed to transform
13. dumbledore's past dumbledore is a
harry potter staple and we learn a lot
about him in both the books and films
however what the films essentially gloss
over entirely is dumbledore's backstory
which includes his relationship with
grindelwald the fatal incident involving
his sister ariana and his relationship
with his brother aberforth 14.
voldemort's past just like dumbledore we
see a lot of voldemort in the books and
films however we certainly get to know
him a lot better in the books for the
most part the films gloss over
voldemort's backstory like the fact that
his mother marapi used a love potion on
his father tom which was actually the
main reason for his inability to feel
love 15. snowballs and voldemort ending
on a lighter note in a scene that was
omitted from the films fred and george
weasley at one point in the
philosopher's stone enchanted a bunch of
snowballs which they directed at the
back of quirrell's head i find this one
hilarious because as is revealed later
that's where voldemort's face was and
that's it for this video did you watch
the films first or read the books first
comment down below
until next time remember
the truth it is a beautiful and terrible
thing and should therefore be treated
with great caution